世界に貢献しているのは
他のものはもう誰でも頑張れば真面目にも得られるもんなんです
今まで説明したこの色界であろうが無色界であろうか
それは仏教独特じゃないんです
この四つの心だけ仏教の世界で
他の宗教ではこれはないと仏教でははっきりと言っているんです
誰に怒られても 私はそれはもうしょうがないんです
お釈迦様は最後に言ったんです
最後にお釈迦様に聞かれたんだから
このまあこんな悟って悟り開くということをあなたは言っていて
他の宗教の人々に修行すれば悟らないんですか？と言ったら
いえ そんなことないんですよ
誰でもこの心清らかにする方法をやれば
それはもうどんな人でも誰でも関係なく悟りますよと
それ論理的にはそうなんです
誰であろうとも無常を体験して
無我を体験して 因果法則の働きを体験すれば
悟りの境地に至るんです
因果法則 お釈迦様の法則ではないし
世の中の法則だから 無常というのは
お釈迦様がわざわざ世界を無常にしてあげたわけじゃなくて
世の中は無常だから それはありのままの姿だから
それを体験するのは誰にでも可能でしょうし
誰でも悟りますよと言ってから
ついでにこう言うんですね
付け加えて言いますけど
今はこの八正道 この中道は
この教えにしかないんだと
ですから  1番目の悟った人
2番目の悟って  3番目に悟った人
4番目に悟った人も 仏教の教えにしかいませんと
世の中 いわゆる仏教でしかないということを
お釈迦様はものすごく肯定的で親切に言ってるだけで
私が言っちゃうとみんな腹が立っちゃうんですね
これは仏教でしかない
他の宗教では全くないよと言っちゃったら
何言ってるんです？自分だけ偉そうなってなっちゃうんです
それはこちらの言い方が良くないんだからそうなっちゃうんだって
お釈迦様はこの亡くなるちょっと前に質問された時でも
ものすごく素晴らしく肯定的に言って
でも真理を言ってるんですね
仏教でしかないということを言ってるんだけど
それによって腹立つことは全く言ってないんですね
相手方は もう方法さえやれば誰でも宗教に関係なく
性別に関係なく 時間に関係なく
いつでも誰にでも得られますよとと言って
それから実践の立場から見ると
今現在ではこの方法あるのはこの教えなきゃだけですよと
そのわけで仏教の中でしか悟った人は見つかりませんと
ですから 相手を批判してないでしょ
他の宗教は下らないんだ
インチキだ 嘘言ってるだとか
僕はよく使っている言葉は一つも使ってないんです
そこら辺はお釈迦様のもうものすごい素晴らしいところなんですね
誰とも戦ってないんです
誰の腹が立つことも何もないんだけど
だからといって自分がぬるぬるとぐにゃぐにゃと教えたわけではないんです
あなたが言うと まあそれもいいわ
これも素晴らしいわとかね
そういう状態でもないし
僕らがちょっと柔軟性持とうと言っちゃったら
こっちに曲がったりあっちに曲がったり
もうなんかどうしようもない情けない人間になってしまっちゃうんですね
じゃあしっかりしろと思っちゃったら
頑固でわがままで もうみんなと喧嘩して
もうとんでもない結果になっちゃうんですね
それはもう我々はそんなもんですけどね
お釈迦様のやり方っていうのはやっぱり素晴らしくて
それは習わなくちゃいけないんです
肯定的で だからといってきちんと物事を言うと
真理を語ると 人を批判する時でも
ちゃんと肯定的でしっかりと批判すると
一番お釈迦様はすっごいきつい言葉をおっしゃったことを今思い浮かんだんだけど
本当に相手をやっつけてやるという気持ちで
もうお釈迦様はきつく言葉を喋った場があったんです
その時でも お釈迦様のこの肯定的な立場っていうのはすごいんです
あるバラモン人の若者が来て
このシャ門の人々をバカにしたんです
あなた方はこのカーストが低いんだと
特に頭が剃るでしょ ムンデカ
サマナ ブラフマパダパッチャ
梵天の足の裏から生まれた連中ではないかと
カンハ インド人は別に白いわけじゃないんだけど
黒人とし すっごいきつい非難の言葉なんです
カンハって カンハってのは黒人という意味なんですね
ですからこの これは人種差別なんですけどね
なんか有権者人間って昔から人種差別してるみたいですね
とにかく どこでもない人間ですけど
今もやってるしね で カンナーっていう言葉を使っちゃうんです
いわゆるアーリー系統じゃなくて黒人だということなんですね
すごい差別用語です そういう言葉でお釈迦様は批判しちゃったんですね
それものすごく言われちゃったら
すぐもう反応しなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでお釈迦様はまああなた方はバラモン人はすぐすぐすごく優れているということでしょうかということで
で まああなたに聞きますけど
あなた昔の遠い昔のこのバラモン人の仙人たちというかね
もうその方々の生き方を勉強したことがありますかと
ただどうせお釈迦様は年上で
もうバラモン系とヒンドゥー教と系統の教えっていうのはとことん勉強していたんだからね
そこら辺でもう学問的にお釈迦様の言葉をみんな聞こうと言ったら
まああまり知りません
そしたらお釈迦様は言うんですね
昔々のバラモン人っていうのは
こういうこういう性格を持っていたんだと
で いろいろ性格あったんだけど
お釈迦様わざわざ選ぶのはこういうことなんですね
例えば昔のバラモンの男が女の人のところに行く場合は
ただ子供を作る目的で行くんだと
ただ遊ぼうとかね 女の人と遊ぼうというそういう欲はなかったんだと
すごく自分を戒めて でもまあ再婚の人々だから子供を作らなくちゃいけないし
ですから 女性には子供を作られる状態に体がそういう状態になったならば
そういう関係も積んであって
それから欲のない生活をする
今どうですかと 今みんな思い立んだら女の人を片っ端から探したりして遊べるんではないかと
それで私がこの昔遠い昔の犬も遠い昔の犬はメス犬が妊娠する状態になってきたら交尾するんだと
犬は今もそうなんですよと
でもあなた方バラモン人がどうでしょうかと
それから５つ例を出すんですね
全部結論はバラモン人というのは犬にも与えないきた連中ことを本当はそれは言ってるんだけど
聞く人は全然気がつかないんです
で 昔のバラモン人はものすごい素晴らしかったんだと
そこで昔のバラモン人が相手を探す場合は
自分の同じバラモン人の女の人しか一緒にいなかったんだと
今見ると どんなカーストの人でも
もう女であればすぐそこに行っちゃうんだと
でも犬だったら昔もメスの犬のところにしか行けませんよと
昔も今も で そこそこ一番きつくお釈迦様はバラモン人を批判した場面なんですけど
その時でもその人にすごく肯定的に昔のバラモン人は素晴らしかったよということを言ってるんですね
ですから バラモン人だからバカですよということを言ってるわけでもないし
そうすると相手方はやっぱりバラモン人もしっかりしなくちゃいけないんだと
我々はちゃんと自分を正さなくちゃいけない
いかなくちゃいけないんだというふうな心に変わるんですね
お釈迦様この野郎という感じにはならないんですね
もう散々けなされてるでしょ
散々けなされてるんだけど
ああ 嫌だ この人ともに
喋りたくないんではなくて
やっぱり私たちは良くないな
こんな状態だったらバラモン人はとんでもないやという風に頑張らなくちゃ
もっとよくいい人間にならなくちゃというふうな明るい方向に行っちゃうんですね
ですから そのお釈迦様の喋り方っていうのは
もう人間というのはとことん習うべきだと思いますよ
僕はそこら辺で やっぱり一応そこら辺に言いたいんですよ
この直接お経に八正道は八ありますよとかね
もうこれは四つありますよ
あれは十三がありますよとかいうよりは
人間としてのこの素晴らしさっていうのは
もう二度とそういうふうな人間が現れてこないんだから
人間としていたお釈迦様のこの偉大なるさっていうのは
そこは昔のインド人がお釈迦様はとんでもないこの呪いを持ってるんだと
みんなわからなかったんだ
お釈迦様のこの性格の素晴らしさっていうのは
この智慧の鋭さと性格の素晴らしさはわからなかった
ですから お釈迦様は何か特別な魔術みたいな何か術を持ってるんだ
だから喋ったら喋った人は仏教徒になってしまう
だから一番無難なのはお釈迦様に顔を合わさないこと
顔を合わしちゃったらもうダメですよ
もう誰もやられちゃいますと
それにお釈迦様もすごい悪口言ってたんだけどね
そう言われた人にお釈迦様説法してね
その人はまた仏教信者さんになったんだって
あなたはね 今仏教を信仰しようと思ってるでしょ？私があなたに何か暗示でもかけたんですかねと
そういうふうな感じで
だからもうそれぐらい説得力あるんです
それは相手を貶さない
本当に貶すべき時はきっちんと言うんです
言うんだけど なんかそのやり方が違うんですね
貶されてもうみんな喜んでいるというか
貶されて元気になったというか
落ち込むことは全くない
でも出家して またそれでも高慢でわがまま言っちゃうと
もう落ち込ませる 落ち込ませるんです
一言葉言って もうそれで全部終わりっていう感じで
出家には厳しかったんだけど
ですからそこはちゃんと比べなく調べなくちゃいけない
出家に喋りしかる場合は
もうすごい恐ろしい言葉でとことん言うんです
一般的な人々に喋る場合は
もう向こう側から悪口言われたら必ず言い返す
言い返すんだけど 全然相手が落ち込まない
すごい元気になる その代わりに仏教徒になってしまう
そこはもう本当に我々日常生活の中で勉強した方がいいところなんですね
だから言葉を使うと いつでも肯定的な言葉でいきましょうと
じゃあソーターパッティ
これからこの 4つの説明に入ります
脱線はやめます ソーターパッティ
ソータっていうのは流れという意味です
流れ カレント フロー そのフローに
流れに 流れっていうことで
ソータ アパッティ 入りましたと
ですから あくまでも俗的な言葉で
俗世間な言葉で理解はできますけど
それでソーターパッティ理解できるわけじゃないんです
ただ 言葉の理解はできる
ソータっていうのは流れ
もう入りました どういう流れかというと
出世間の流れ 煩悩をなくす流れに過程に入ったと
我々はずっと循環しているんですね
生命 心っていうのは全然成長しないんです
心は 普通だったら神になっても人間になっても勉強しても
心は ただ 僕はいつでも言う言葉だから回転するだけであって
進化するわけじゃないんだと
世の中で一般的な考え方あるんですね
輪廻転生する 信じてる人々はこう言うんですね
人間が輪廻転生して 徐々に徐々に魂が浄化していくんだと
ですから やがて高次元的に輪廻転生したら
そこでもう最終的に神と一緒になるんだというふうに言ってる人々がいるんです
新興宗教の中でもあるんです
そういうふうに輪廻転生して魂は浄化するんだとかね
我々ようなのはそんな簡単に浄化するわけじゃないんです
進化はしない する 変化はする
変化と進化は違うんだと
例えば私は今日は落ち込んでる心があって
次明日はすごいもう自信満々の心があるんだと
それだったら明後日はさらに良くなるかというと
そうじゃないんです 次また落ち込んだりするかもしれませんし
またいい心がある それだったらもう波だけであって
進化というものはない
進化っていうのはある方向でずっと前へ前へ前へ堕落することがなく進むことであって
でも人間の生命を見ると
もう堕落することはもう毎日 3時で起こりますから
7時ぐらいでしっかりしましょうと思った人は
7時1分来たところでもう堕落しちゃうんだから
ですからもうそういう心ですから
変化はある でも進化はない
ですから我々はもう動いているならば
このサイクルみたいな感じである
あの なんていますかね
この軌道その なんています？え？うん
その軌道 軌道ですか その道
まあもうサイクルみたいな感じで
まあずっとこの同じ軌道で動いているだけで
もうそれは変化しない
そこでもしほんのわずかでもこの向きを変えちゃったらどうなるかというと
まあ衛星の場合はね 衛星はもうずっと地球をぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってるでしょ
そこでもし他のサテライトに乗って乗っていて
誰かがあの衛星に足ででも蹴っ飛ばしちゃえば
あの軌道からちょっと外れちゃえば
もう分からない もう他の方向行ってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この我々の心の流れをほんの僅かに方向性変える
方向性変えちゃったらもう止まることはできない
もうまっすぐに行ってしまっちゃうんです
ですから その流れに入ったという意味でソーターパットと言うんです
いろんな言葉で言うなら
聖者の流れで入った出世間の流れに入ったこととかね
悟りの道に入ったとかね
まあ悟りの道に入ったという風に理解した方がもっと分かりやすくていいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
違う言葉で申し上げるならば
我々の心の回転する方向
この方向でいくら回転しても全然進化がない
いくら徳を積んで天国に生まれ変わっても
それは進化ではなくて変化だけなんです
そこでカルマが消えちゃったところで
他のところで生まれ変わらなくちゃいけない
神が人間になったら人間であって神ではないし
神でいた人が犬に生まれ変わっちゃったら
犬であって神では全くないし
私は過去生で何者かでしたかわからないでしょうに
それに関係ない 今は人間であって
人間として生きるしか方法はない
例えば誰かの超能力者に言ってもらっても
あなたは過去世でアメリカの大統領でしたと言ってもらったって
僕にとってはもう全然関係もない
何もない ただのくだらない
何の能力も知識も力もない
ただの人間だけですからね
私は過去世でアメリカの大統領でしたから
あなた方私の言うことを聞きなさいと
誰も聞いてくれないし
それは何の意味もないんですね
ですから進化はまるっきりなし
過去世で神様でいても
全然もうしょうがないんですよ
今世で人間だったら それでこの心のこの方向性を変える
変えちゃったら悟りの道に入る方向性変えるということは
ヴィパッサナーの修行なんです
この大胆な修行方法っていうのは
その心の方向性 ほんのわずかに変えるためなんです
で これからそこらの説明いたしますけど
この生命はすべての生命が生きていきたい
生きていきたいという希望で生きているんです
生きていきたいと思っているのは
自分が死ぬんだからなんです
どう頑張っても死ぬ それだったら
智慧のある人だったら頑張らないんです
生きていきたいと 無駄だから
どうしても結果が得られないならば
やめた方がいいでしょうに
やる必要はないんです
猿でミスを組もうとする
一回二回やってみたっていいんだけど
二回やった見たところで全然ミス組めないんですね
それだったらアホが死ぬまで組もうとする
知恵ある人は一回 あ これは猿だからミスはもう組みないんだけど
やめよう やめたと やめるでしょうに
生命のおかしいことっていうのは
いつでも我々は死の死を
死を体現しているんです
だから全ての生命はいつでも不安で
心が心配で 恐怖感で覆われているんです
誰にでも たまに私と私にいるもん
あんたの問題は何ですか？と言ったら
ものすごい不安があるんだとか
恐怖感があるんだとか言うんだけど
別にそれ何とかしてちょうだいと言ったって
何とかしてあげることできませんよ
これは全ての生命がもう全生命が不安で恐怖感で覆われているんだから
で それはどういう不安か恐怖
恐怖感かと 本人それわかってないんだけどね
僕はそれで聞くんです
きっと あんた何に不安ですかと
将来のこととか 仕事のこととか
体のこととか そういうことを言うんですね
体のこと 不安だから僕に何かしてあげることできますか？じゃああなたの体に樹脂とかプラスチックでも入れちゃって
もう病気にならないようにしてあげますと
それできないでしょうに
プラスチックで体入れ替えちゃったらもう人間でなくなっちゃうでしょうに
蝋人形にしてあげますよとかね
体のこと不安だったら蝋人形にでもしてあげるしか方法ないでしょうに
そうすると火事が起こるまではもう安全ですけど
どうしてもできないんですよ
でもその不安やら恐怖感というのは全ての生命にあるんです
そこで生命というのはどう考えるかというと
とにかく生きることはもう勝負だと
とにかく必死で生きるために頑張ることですよと
死ぬんだからと 言って生きていきたい
生きていきたい 生きたいという必死で頑張る
それは生きるということなんです
死なないようにどうすればいいかと
みんな元気や明るだと言うんだけど
世の中で明るい生命はいるわけないんですよ
根っこから暗いんです
生きていきたい 生きていきたいと
それで金儲かるは 権力をつくるは
エアロビクスするは 運動するは
ああだこうだ健康食品食べるはもうキリがない
やってるんですね そこですごい元気でありとあらゆる習い事をしたり
社交ダンスを習ったり
おしゃれしたりすると
明るい人やと思う 根元から徹底的に暗いんです
すごい明るい人だったら付き合ってみてください
明るい人と付き合うとものすごいリラックスするはずなんです
そういう元気臭で頑張ってる人と付き合ってみたらどう感じるんですか？ものすごいストレス感じるでしょ
イライラと落ち着きがないとかね
あ もう次になんとか行かなくちゃとか
これからダンスの稽古がありますから
これからお習字の稽古がありますからとかね
だから根元から暗いんですよ
それはしょうがないんですけど
生命はそんなもんで それでとにかく生きていきたいと努力する
それで私は聞きたいのは
じゃあ成功した人は一人いますか？年取らなかった人
病気にならなかった人
死ななかった人は一人いますか？というと
一人もいない やってる本人も瞬間瞬間知ってるんです
確実に死ぬんだと 確実に病気になるんだと
確実に自分が年取るんだと
確実に自分の美しさは消えちゃうんだと
それだったらね バカじゃないかと
やめた方がいいでしょ
そのやり方は それでも頑張る
それでも頑張るってな
それは猿を持って水を汲むことと同じなんです
それでキリがない いくら汲んでも汲めないんだから
それでどうしたってもこれ理解しない
私は水が必要ですから
これで水を汲みます とにかく必要だから汲みますよと
あんたみたいな怠け者でそんなやめること私はしませんよと
偉そうな説教までするんです
説教するならじゃあ勝手にそれしろというのは言うんですけど
僕らはね じゃあ勝手にしろと
説教しないんだったら
いい加減やめたらと言うんです
猿で水汲むことは だからこの生きるということは猿で水汲むことと同じで
最終的な結果はもうゼロと
何もなしと そこで存在になると
みんな生きていきたがる
それは何ですかというと
生きていきたいという欲望がある
渇愛がある なんで渇愛が生まれたかというと
自分が死ぬんだから 無常だからなんです
無常は嫌だと思うんだからなんです
無常の代わりに それにあるものをほしがっちゃうんです
それにあるものに執着するんです
そこで頭の中で永遠な概念膨らませちゃうんです
永遠な天国 永遠な命 不死なる魂と
いろんな理想を作る 作ってなんか自己暗示で楽しがってる
魂は永遠だ 私は死んでも魂は死なないんだとか
あれは自己マインドコントロールなんです
それ哲学的な宗教なんか作って
どうすれば永遠不滅の魂を獲得できますか？という方法論まで書く
根拠は全てここから生まれるんです
たとえ私はいつでも言うことなんです
たとえ例えば永遠の魂があるならば
リラックスすればいいでしょ
もし私の私には永遠不滅の魂がある
ああ そうあるの じゃあ私はリラックスします
別に慌てなくてもいいでしょう
年取ったってもいいんじゃないんですか？魂は永遠だから
病気になったっても まあそんな短い人生で病気なんて早く死んだ方がいいやと
それ早く死ねなかったら自殺でもしてやろうと
なぜならば そうすると永遠の魂の境地に行くんだから
自殺したっても平気しど
だっても平気し 仕事は失敗してだっても倒産してても何のことないんですよ
それだったら徹底的にリラックスした方がいいんですよ
もし永遠の魂があるならば
でも誰一人分かってないんだ
あるかないかと みんな僕から言えば嘘なんですね
みんな言ってるのは嘘なんだ
魂があるかないかという話ではなくて
魂があるんだあるんだとおっしゃってる方々が言ってるのは嘘なんですよ
本人が知らないんです
もし魂があると知ったならば
その瞬間からもう完璧にリラックスする
完璧にやりたい放題のことをやって楽しく生きてるんです
川に飛んでみる 山を登って
もう何でもいいんだから
別にやりたいことは そういう大胆なことはもう男性だったらやりたくなりますよ
僕でもたまにやりたくはなるんだけどね
そういうもう 200 キロぐらい車で運転できれば
スピード出したらどうなるんですか
まあでも死ぬのは怖いんだからやらないですね
ですから もう死んだっても大丈夫だと
魂というものあるということだったらやりますよ
それだって私は運転免許証なくてもやってみるんです
もし魂は永遠だ知っていたならば
なぜならば事故を起こしたってもいいし
他の人死んだっても別に
その人はもう分かったもんだからね
別に すごい車いっぱいある道路で
もうこうやってぐちゃぐちゃにしていかに速く行けるかどうかね
人が歩くところにも車出していけるかないかと
映画でなんかやってるような感じで
実際にやってみたいとかね
そういう大胆なことは
男にとってはそれすごい刺激的で面白いし
女性にはそれなりの楽しみが別にあるし
でもそれは大胆なことはね
誰でもやらないということは結局本当にあなたは信じていますか？という疑問にはなるんです
永遠な魂があるということは
そこでその人 魂あるんだからあると私は信じているんだから
一生懸命真面目に行儀よく
正しく 戒律を守って修行して生活しているんだと言うんです
毎日ちゃんとお祈りしたりして
讃経したりして修行しているんだと
なぜなら私は霊魂霊を信じているのだ
そんなに弱いもんか どれっていうのはまた聞きたくなるんですね
ちょっと嘘ついただけで汚れるとかね
ちょっと人を嫉妬したことだけで汚れる霊魂だったら
大した霊魂じゃないでしょう
だからそういうことなんですよ
人間の無知の世界っていうのは
そこで問題は 無常である
我々は確実に死ぬ 瞬間の現象でしかない存在っていうのは
その現象を生き続けてほしがっちゃう
なぜならば現象消えることを知るんだから
花火みたいなもんなんですね
花火は綺麗だから ずっとあってほしいと思うことと同じなんですね
ずっと花火で もう空の上で巨大な催し物を作って
そのまま消してほしいと
でもそれはありえない話なんですね
ですから 無常から人間には
愚か者には渇愛が生まれるんです
諦めではなくて それで生きていきたいと努力する
それで死んじゃう 死んでももう心のエネルギーは消えないし
もう消えないと言ったらおかしい言葉ですけど
今も生滅変化していくんだから
同じ生滅変化 生滅変化で続けていっちゃうし
輪廻転生をする どこまで輪廻転生したっても同じだから
状況は死ぬんだから無常だから
渇愛は永遠に消えない
ですから人間というのは人間じゃなくて
生命が永遠に生きていきたいという努力をするんです
そこで仏教はちょっと待てと
ありのまま見ろと 死ぬんだと
頑張っても無駄だと 無常だと
瞬間だけの存在だと 幻想だと
それには永遠というものは成り立たないでしょうと
だから諦めちゃう なるほど
これ無駄だと 猿に水をくんだって意味がないんだと
なるほどと納得する心なんですね
じゃあやめようと 生きていきたいという気持ち
それはもう 第1段階目の目の覚めるステップなんですね
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想はとことん無常を観察しろと
無我を見ろと 苦を苦しみということを見ろと
言ってるんです だからヴィパッサナー瞑想と世の中のサマーディ瞑想は全く違うと我々言うのはその立場なんです
で 無常は他の瞑想で見ないわけじゃないんだけど
体はやっぱり消えるんだとかね
体消えても魂というまた出てくるんだから
結局もう仏教の無常ではなくなっちゃうんですね
で この魂の概念にしたっても
人間のこれは希望であって
永遠にあってほしいという渇愛だけのことで
それで物事は連続して変化するんだから
この連続性あるんですね
それを誤解して永遠だと言うんですね
例えば あの 何といいますか
もうブドウの種を植えたらちゃんとブドウの芽が出て
ブドウの葉っぱが出て
ブドウのツルが出て ブドウの花が咲いて
ブドウの実が実ると これは物事の連続性なんですね
無常ですけど いい加減な無常ではない
因果法則の無常だから
ガラスに石を投げちゃったらガラスは割れるのであって
割れたガラスに石を投げられて投げられたら
すぐ割れたガラスがまた元に戻ったということはありえない
因果法則っていうのはそういうもので
ですから そこには法則がありますから
ちゃんとしているんですよ
無常は 人間はちゃんとしていないんだけど
無常自体はちゃんとしているんです
我々いくら嫌であろうとも
年取る時は年取る 癌になる時はちゃんとそれはなる
死ぬ時はちゃんとする
物事はもうちゃんと起こるんです
決まってる時は そこら辺ちょっと誤解するんですね
そこら辺は それで自分として心の流れがあるんだから自分がいるんじゃないかと誤解する
その誤解に永遠に生きていきたいという希望を足す
足して合計は魂があるという合計が出るんです
ですから これはこの 2つの妄想概念足したところで出てきた結果なんですね
そこで魂がないんだと仏教で言うと
どうせそれは否定的な言葉だから
みんな何言ってるんですか
と怒ったりもする あなたの話は全く非道徳的で危ないのではないかと
魂があるということで
神様がいるということで
地獄があるということで
みんなもう道徳を守って生きているのではないかというかもしれませんし
ですから 魂実体ないということは
みんなに怒られる言葉なんですね
そこら辺でもお釈迦様はすごく気をつけているんです
魂がないんだ 無我論だ
無我論だとか言って人にぶち当たっても
喧嘩した得は一つもないんです
そうじゃなくて あなたの体を見てくださいと
あなたの体はずっとそのまんまであったんですかと
いえ 違います 変わりましたか？はい
変わりましたと 変わるものは
永遠なものだとあなたは思いますか？無常なものだと思いますかと
私は体は無常だと思いますと
無常というものはすごいいいものですか？あるいは悪いものですかと
いわゆるドゥッカですか？スッカですかと
楽ですか？苦ですかと
言えば無常たるものはやっぱり嫌ですね
苦ですね じゃあ無常であって
なおかつ苦であって そういうものは永遠だ
魂だと言えますかと いいえ
それは言えませんと でお釈迦様
じゃあだから体は色蘊は無常であって
苦であって無我であります
何も喧嘩することないでしょう
すごい丁寧に素晴らしく話を続けていくんです
本人も何もショックを受けずに無常論を飲み込んでしまっちゃうんです
だからお経でずっとその話をそのまま記録しているんだから
色蘊は変化するかしないか
変化する 変化するものは常か無常か
無常である 無常 変化して無常たるものは苦から苦であると
変化して無常たるもので
無常であって苦であるものは
私の我だと言えるのですか？いいえ
言えませんと 故に色蘊は無我であると
そこで受蘊・想蘊・行蘊・色蘊で説明しちゃうんですね
あの説法の仕方っていうのはもう最高であって
それ以上はもう言えないんです
そこを弁慶する我々は
やっぱりお釈迦様は無我をおっしゃっているんだと
無我論だと言っちゃったところで
もうやられちゃうんです
それは我々の間違いであって
それでもある学者の方々はもうそれでも我があってほしいんだから
お釈迦様は無我だ無我だと言ってないんだから
やっぱりお釈迦様はこの無我でないものは我で取るのは嫌で
無我だと言っただけであって
真我は否定していないんだと
いわゆる何て言いますか
自我は否定するんであって
自己は否定していないんだとか
よく言葉で遊んで まあバカには変わりないんですね
やっぱり 見つかってないという
感じてないという このお釈迦様のあの鋭さっていうのは
会話の話 人にショックを与えないで
すごい丁寧に導いていくんですね
智慧の方向 だから僕らにとってはもう即加えることはもう全く不可能で
で ほんのわずかな教えを説明するしかできないんですね
だから仏教の話を聞くだけでも
もう人間変わりますよ
人間性を飛び出すと飛んでしまっちゃうんです
ものすごく素晴らしくなっちゃうんですね
すごい教えなんです 他の話とは違って
ですから 耳あるならば法を聞けと
脳細胞あるならばね 法のことを考えなさいと
妄想したければね そこら辺の方向で妄想して
私の頭も皆様と同じくもうよく回転します
もしかすると私の方がえらく回転するかもしれませんし
ですから 余計な妄想じゃなくて
そういう心理的な世界でいろんなことを考えれば
まあそれぐらい役に立つんです
あってほしい 加えてほしいじゃなくて
なぜ無常か 何が因果法則かとかね
この教えはどんな意味かどうか
例えばカーナン・ゴマー・ウパッチャガという言葉
前書いたでしょ カーナン
この瞬間 この出会い そこで宇宙のことを考えたりして
本当に自分の人間の人生っていうのは本当に短いものかとかね
感じてみたりとか そういう風に法にのっとって妄想すれば
それも結構役に立つんです
それでは頭はどうせ妄想するんだったら
いい妄想してやろうと
そうするとすごく結局すごく智慧っていうのはね
発達していきますよ 耳あるならば法を聞いた方がいいし
目があるならば法を読んだ方がいいし
体があるならばそれを持って体のこと体験でもして瞑想でもすればいいっていう風に我々は言ってますけどね
誰もやってませんだけど
で そこでこのよるかというのは
よるかじゃなくて よるどうですか
このよる このそうか この流れに入ったということは
このヴィパッサナー瞑想によって
本当の姿は無常であると
本当のもの全て瞬間的な現象であると
現象と現象の噛み合わせによって新しい現象が生まれるのであって
その現象もすぐ消えてしまうんだと
何もこんなところで何もつかまるものもないんだと
この方向では永遠というものは得られないということにすぐ納得してしまっちゃう
この納得する瞬間というのはすごい瞬間なんです
もう変わらない その人の心変わることは不可能なんです
ありのまま無常であることを見たんだから
それでも生きてきなさいと言ったっても
もうその人は二度とはもうやらない
もう悟れっていうのは
あるい他のすごい俗っぽい言葉で言えば
この無常についてもうもう納得してしまっちゃうんですね
それはただもう私たちの納得と違って
もう修行してとくとんとくとんとくとん見たところで